since introducing New National Security
laws nearly a decade ago Beijing has
increasingly tightened its control and
its scrutiny of people and activities in
China now changes to counter Espionage
regulations are coming into effect on
Saturday that expand the number of
activities considered as spying
they include a ban on the transfer of
any information authorities consider
relates to National Security and expand
the definition of Espionage to include
cyber attacks against State
organizations and information
infrastructure it follows the general
Trend
in recent years in the development of
Chinese law towards more emphasis on
National Security more control by the
Communist Party of important areas of
the state
the changes bolstered more than a dozen
new or amended laws under which people
can be banned from leaving China
and analysts say it's likely to raise
concern among foreigners and business
people operating in the country of
coming under greater scrutiny exit bands
have been applied in China for many
years and rights groups note they are
being increasingly used against both
Chinese Nationals and foreigners under
the revised counter-espionage laws they
can be imposed on anyone under
investigation
human rights researcher Fung Chong Yi
was prevented from leaving China in
2017. he was detained for 10 days in a
hotel room before being allowed to fly
out to Australia if I go there anytime
they will get Henry right away so that's
um describe law actually
is so
vague so ambiguous that they can they
can use it to fabricate a case to
prosecute anyone for for political uh
purpose Beijing says the changes aim to
protect China every country has the
right to safeguard its National Security
through domestic legislation in fact
this is a common practice of all
countries the changes come as China's
borders open for foreign visitors after
three years of covid-19 restrictions but
some experts say the broad and vague
scope of the revisions may cause some
businesses and individuals to question
how welcome they really are Jessica
Washington Al Jazeera Beijing